“‘Good morning!’ said Bilbo,
and he meant it.
“‘What do you mean?’ Gandalf said.
“‘Do you wish me a good morning,
“or mean that it is a good morning whether
I want it or not;
“or that you feel good this morning; or
that it is a morning to be good on?’
“‘All of them at once,’ said Bilbo.
“‘What a lot of things you do use
good morning for!’ said Gandalf.”
What Gandalf is stubbornly ignoring
in that conversation,
because there’s no way that a wizard who’s
lived in Middle Earth for 3,000 years
doesn’t understand “good morning” --
but anyway, what he’s stubbornly ignoring
is that the phrase “good morning”
doesn’t usually convey information at all.
Instead, it serves a social function.
It is a greeting.
Expressions like this are called
“phatic expressions”.
They’re phrases where the semantic information
is much less important than the
pragmatic information.
And generally, it’s to do with politeness.
“How are you”, “How's it going” and
“Hello” are all phrases
that are made up of different words but mean
approximately the same thing,
to the point that you can switch them up fairly
interchangeably,
as long as they're tonally appropriate and
you're used to them.
If you’re an American in Britain,
it might be quite jarring to be asked
“you alright?” as a greeting.
For many North Americans, “are you alright”
is not a phatic expression,
so “Are you all right?”
expresses genuine concern.
Also, it probably won’t be “you alright?”,
it’ll just be “y'arigh?”.
The other way around: applies to “What's up?”.
For most Britons it’s an expression of concern,
not a greeting:
it’s not phatic in British English.
Phatic expressions change with time.
“How do you do?”
eroded over time to “Howdy do” and then
“howdy”,
but all those sound dated and formal to most
modern listeners.
And these changes happen all the time!
It’s now usual to reply to ”thank you”
with “no problem.”
But that’s a bit contentious because for
some, usually older, folks
“no problem” is not phatic and it’s
impolite:
it should be “you’re welcome” instead.
Which, to many younger folks,
also sounds impolite!
We’re going to have these generational differences
as long as language continues to change.
So why do we bother with phatic expressions
at all?
Why is it rude to just immediately jump to
what you actually want to say?
Well, greetings are a way to either acknowledge
another person,
to initiate conversation by establishing a
relationship,
or they're a verbal sort of handshake
to make sure everyone’s paying attention.
Depending on the phatic expression we choose,
we can convey a hierarchical relation or intent.
We can use them for saying goodbye.
There are also phatic expressions for “backchanneling”,
which is how we express that
we are actively listening.
Those serve the pragmatic function of demonstrating
that, yes, you are listening,
and that you don't desire to be the one talking
at the moment. You're not going to interrupt.
This is why backchannels often happen at the
end of sentences;
they are the listener recognizing that they
could jump into the conversation at this point,
but they are choosing to
continue to listen instead.
Their prevalence varies from language to language,
and culture to culture,
which can lead to misunderstandings.
In Japanese, backchanneling is so ubiquitous
that foreign businesspeople
sometimes mistake it for agreement,
and think that people are saying
“okay, I agree” and not
“okay, I understand you, carry on”.
Not all phatic expressions are treated equally
by everyone.
So look out for them.
They are everywhere.
Play around with them and use unusual ones
if you want… just…
don’t be Gandalf.
My co-author Gretchen McCulloch’s new book
Because Internet
includes a bit on why we stress out so much
about phatic expressions in email:
whether you should start that message with
“Hi” or “Dear Name” or something else entirely.
There are links to her book in the description!